well this morning a top u.s envoys
telling the taliban to stop their
military offensive to take control of
afghanistan
taliban fighters captured another city
yesterday the sixth major city they've
seized ahead of the final withdrawal of
u.s
troops charlie dagetta recently returned
from a trip to afghanistan charlie good
morning
the return of the taliban is
unfortunately starting to look
inevitable
well vlad it's hard to see what's going
to stop it
when we were there just a few weeks ago
the taliban were rampaging across the
rural areas but they were stopping
short of these city centers surrounding
them the thought thing was that they
were going to wait until all u.s forces
leave by the end of the month
before launching a large-scale offensive
but as we can see
that's already underway
the takeover the northern city of kunduz
was textbook taliban
blast their way in early in the morning
spark a mass panic among residents
sprint to the city center
raise their flag declare victory leave
a trail of destruction behind
thousands have fled the fighting
[Music]
we're so exhausted this evacuee said how
long will it be like this
who can be happy with this situation
conduce is the biggest strategic and
symbolic trophy
in a rapid fire string of victories that
has seen city centers fall like
dominoes six provincial capitals and
counting
in some cases afghan forces are folding
without a fight
we were told one taliban tactic is to
persuade local elders to convince
afghan soldiers to drop their weapons
rather than face certain defeat
and death even giving them cash to get
back home
in the past u.s ground forces have
worked with afghan commandos to dislodge
taliban fighters from city centers
this time the u.s military has made
clear america
will not waver from the pull-out plan
this is their country these are their
these are their military forces
these are their provincial capitals
they're people to defend
and it's really going to come down to
the leadership that they're willing to
exude here at this particular moment
in the absence of that afghan leadership
the white house and the world
now have to decide right decide on how
much they're willing to tolerate from
the taliban
in terms of civilian casualties in terms
of threatening kabul before they're
willing to intervene
or decide to let the afghan government
go it alone
tony what is the mission if there's a
mission charlie dagetta in london for us
charlie thank you very much